today I'm going to talk about the seven
signs that you are successful even if
you don't feel like it so one of the
hardest things that entrepreneurs have
to go through when you're certain the
business is you're putting a lot of work
you feel like you're grinding it you're
hustling it and you're not getting the
results that you want you're not getting
the customers yet you're not getting the
growth you thought you'd be a lot
further ahead than you are and a lot of
people give up too soon a lot of people
give up before the momentum allows them
to be carried to achieve their goals and
to have the impact that they want they
just quit too soon so today's video is
going to talk about the seven signs that
you're on the right path that you are
secretly successful even if it doesn't
feel like you actually are so number one
is your customer C value at the end of
the day business is providing value if
you want to make money to provide value
when I make more money you got to
provide more value if your customers are
liking what you do they're saying man I
couldn't imagine my life for my business
without you that's a really good sign it
may be that you're only helping one
person though or five people are ten
people you want to be helping thousands
or hundreds of thousands or millions but
a one of my first mentors used to tell
me that if you can sell one person you
can sell a thousand people you can sell
a hundred thousand people and so that's
the start right if your customers hate
what you do if they're apathetic if they
don't like it at all they're not using
it that's a big problem but if your
customers do appreciate your service
they're finding value in what you do
then it's a sign that you're on the
right path
number two is that you're getting
referrals referrals and word of mouth
business is one of the fastest ways to
grow your company it's one of the most
effective it's of one of the least
costly because your customers are
telling other people and the word is
getting out at the start though it takes
time to build up because you may only
have one customer and so you know that
one customer may not be telling a
thousand people it's harder to get the
word-of-mouth multiplier effect
happening when you're really small but
are you getting any referrals right are
the people that you're connecting to
that you're meeting up with kind of form
Alliance partners with customers have
already bought from you is there any
kind of word-of-mouth happening right do
people meet you and they want to tell
somebody else about it not not happening
on the mass scale obviously writer would
be watching this video it's not
happening for you in a big way yet but
is it happen in this small way do people
see the value in what you're doing
enough that they want to share it with
somebody else because if you're getting
one or two new customers or leads coming
in because somebody referred them to you
then you are on the right path and that
will continue going just keep what
you're doing keep the momentum going and
you will achieve your goals
number three is you're getting better as
I mentioned at the top business about
providing value so to provide value you
need to learn how to give good value and
that comes from you getting better what
you're doing whatever your craft is
whether you're making YouTube videos
whether you're making a product whether
you're selling t-shirts whatever it is
that your company is all about you need
to be getting better and so look at what
you're producing today and look at what
you did last week and look at what you
did last month is it better I could look
at my youtube channel and look at what
I've done I could look at where I was
last month where it was six months ago
where I was last year you can say I've
gotten better and that's a good sign
because the more that I can get better
the more value I will bring to you guys
and the more my business will grow so
are you getting better at your craft or
your skills improving because if they
are then that will help the momentum
grow as long as you will continue to get
better it's a sign that you're on the
right path
if you stalled if you're not growing
you're not getting better it's the same
output the same result then it's hard to
imagine the business really taking off
number four is that you're seeing growth
you're not seeing the growth that you
want you're not seeing the growth that
you expect it it's almost never the
growth you expected right if you make
your business plan and you have your
best-case scenario and the realistic
case scenario and the worst case
scenario it's often worse than the worst
case scenario right and that's a huge
letdown for a lot of entrepreneurs when
they're starting up like I never thought
it would be this bad like I read about
how hard it was but isn't expected to be
this hard this is crazy so the growth
may not be where you want it to be but
are you getting any kind of growth like
are you seeing more people coming to
your website are you seeing more emails
coming in more leads happening are you
getting more followers on your social
accounts are you getting more engagement
are you getting some kind of growth
because if you get some kind of growth
you know percentage that's pretty high
right if you have two customers and you
get one more customer that's a 50%
growth that's pretty good right
obviously we'll continue that
exponential rise but showing that you
have some kind of growth some kind of
momentum is a positive sign and again we
get frustrated early because it's not
happening soon enough but if you are
having some growth in your business no
matter how small is a sign that you're
on the right
number five is that your environment is
changing a lot of times as an
entrepreneur it's really hard because we
don't have the people around us that we
need to we don't have parents or
entrepreneurs we don't have friends who
are entrepreneurs we don't have people
who can guide us some interest to be
what we want to be and so to do that you
need to create an environment yourself
right not just blame them for not you
know being there for you and not giving
the guidance that you need and say all
these people were successful because
they had a silver spoon they were gifted
all this money who cares like do your
thing right what are you gonna do just
sit here and be upset for the rest of
your life
go get yours there's nothing holding you
back from doing what you should be doing
create an environment for yourself right
are you are you watching these kinds of
YouTube videos to invest in yourself or
make yourself better are you do you have
a morning routine do you have habits in
the morn are you reading from successful
entrepreneurs do you have something that
motivates you on a regular basis if your
environment is changing if your
environment is growing what it does it
makes you become better the more you
hang around successful entrepreneurs
even if it's not face to face in person
just online with video the more you hang
around them the more that magic dust
will rub off on you and the more your
mindset will start to shift and so if
you're feeling that your mindset of
shifting you're feeling like you're
starting to thing bigger you're starting
to play a bigger game like even if it's
just in your mind you feel like you've
grown in your learning the results might
not speak for themselves yet but it's a
sign that you're on the right path if
you're filling your head with knowledge
from these successful people who've done
what you're trying to do it will make
you better and so that changing of the
environment changing maybe your friends
that you're hanging out with changing
the resources that you read in the
morning changing your habits in your
structure to support something that's
more growth oriented towards a goal that
you want to accomplish if you're doing
that then it's a sign that you're on the
right path
number six is your trying new things
most businesses don't end up with the
business that they start doing so many
business pivot and they change and it
may be a massive difference it may be
something totally unrelated to what you
started with or it might be a series of
minor changes but quite often the
initial business plan that you have
coming out of the gate is not the
business plan that ends up making you
successful and so the way to find that
success path is to try to think you got
experiment you got to add new new new
parts to your business parts to your
process new products new services new
tweaks you need to constantly be trying
things and most things will fail like
that's part of being a success is
failing over and over and over again and
you will fail way more than you succeed
but hopefully all those fails are just
small failures it's a small failure get
it in we're going to try something else
I'm going to try something else going to
try something and when you're trying all
those things it feels like you're not
successful because you haven't found the
thing that can help you explode and that
may feel like you want to give up and
you want to quit but the fact that you
are trying things constantly over and
over and over and over again eventually
you will find something the real risk is
not trying anything new is just trying
to do the same thing repeatedly and not
getting results and expecting something
big to happen it will only happen from
you constantly testing tweaking and try
new things so if you are trying those
new things you are constantly innovating
are trying to add something new
consistently to your business there's a
sign that you're on the right path
and number seven and the most important
one of all for me is that you still love
it like you can't help but do it
you know all the odds are against you
everybody is telling you that you're
crazy it's not the logical smart safe
thing to do doesn't really make any
sense you just have to do it there's
something inside you that says I need to
do this I don't know why I'm doing this
I love it like it makes me come alive I
need to continue to do it and there's
this you know debate I guess in the
entrepreneurial world of when do you
quit is it that I will never quit I will
keep going I will constantly would never
give up go go go and others I say hey
you know quit move on and go do
something else for me it comes down to
as long as you love it you owe it to
yourself to keep going because that's
what's going to get you through that's
what's going to get you through all the
experiments and the trials and the
failures and all the crap that comes
with running the business is that you
still love it it's like you enjoy the
process you're not so addicted to the
outcome of getting a sale or getting
this big goal that's not the main reason
for doing it you're doing it because you
love the work like I love making these
YouTube videos I love watching my
youtube videos I love the work it's not
just because I want to hit a million
subscribers or reach a billion
entrepreneurs I love the process I would
do it even if I never hit a billion
entrepreneurs because it makes me come
alive because I look forward to doing it
if I stopped loving making videos then I
should move on to something else and
that can happen so the sign that you're
on the right path and that you will be
successful is that you still love the
work and the minute you stop loving the
work the minute you dread having to go
in and do the stuff that's on that paper
your check boxes you can only force
yourself to do something for so long and
then you gotta you got to stop it and
change and find the next thing that
makes you come a lot because if you do
not love your business you will
so those are my tips on the seven signs
that you are successful and on the path
of success even if it doesn't feel like
it I'd love to know which one resonated
the most with you and why as well as
what you might add to the list is there
an eighth ninth or tenth one that I'm
missing leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon